hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to at bed of night
uh we definitely
learned something very special that i'm
gonna learn again right now just to
remind you what it was
not me i know what it was okay number
one we gotta go to floor
one all right so we just gotta find
wherever this ghost may be whoever it
may be
why ever they may be not my business
i would like to reiterate that none of
this is my business i really shouldn't
be here
and and frankly i don't know why i still
am
can he get me on this floor um
one of these days he's gonna be in that
elevator and i'm not gonna be ready for
it
all right let's do this buddy boo
hey what is up hi
oh boy i don't hear him
might not be here sure oh my god no
god kill me don't kill me jesus christ
where am i going i don't even know screw
you i'm going in here
oh it's my room god damn i came to my
room
wow did i panic over nothing because i
never did hear his voice
no oh hey bud
how you doing how you doing it was
definitely him he was just being quiet
he was being sneaky but he can only
sneak so much when i'm around
oh there it is
fun i really wonder how they do that in
like the game programming
i got to learn programming someday he
went to the left but the problem is left
is the way i needed to go
unless i didn't need to go that way and
i'm going to go to the right which is
exactly what i'm going to do
don't kill me
oh it's pointing the other way oh god i
think this loops around doesn't it
doesn't it it does not this is the dead
end
this is the dead end god i'm an idiot
hey what's up bud you want to kill
someone who's dumb
you want to kill a dummy would you like
a free dum-dum kill
[Music]
music is getting concerningly floaty
all right it's fading away i'm assuming
i'm good
maybe it's all good
it's all fine
that mean you're close i don't hear
footsteps
ah no i think i might have gone the
wrong way
[Music]
i don't know i don't know where he is
here this one oh god
is this where i wanted to be i don't
know yeah
okay either way i got a little bit of a
reprieve it might have been in here
might not have been i don't know
is anyone there no definitely not in
here it's probably way on the other side
of the whole building but just looks
like the compass was pointing through
this
okay i'm guessing it was a whole lot of
nothing i don't know if i can
you smell a what okay where does this go
i'm just gonna keep moving i can't be
hiding forever
i can't hide forever if i hide forever
i'm just a coward
oh i'm a coward i'm a goddamn coward
where are you at [ __ ] where are you at
try me [ __ ] here
got it nailed it i'm winning this oh
[ __ ]
god damn it stark hello is anyone there
goddammit i'm going out again
okay so if it's not there yet it must be
around this corner
oh my god he's right behind me i'm going
in oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god
oh freak me oh
god no
hello hi that's
what is that
[Music]
thanks for showing that to me really
appreciate that really preach big preach
on that
how about i talk to this this dude here
dr boze
dr bozey
[Music]
you dead seems like you might be dead i
saw you holding up a dead animal on a
wire
a wire you say
i realized
so i asked him to think of something
nice he could do for me
i was surprised he came up with an idea
right away was the idea of the uh
you know i should probably just ask
the stairs what happened to her she fell
down the stairs
she was too drunk to know what she was
doing
it was the reason rose got in touch with
me
oh you're awfully calm about that
damn 10 year olds in there drinking
problems let me tell you
i saw amy drinking something she didn't
seem to like it
what was it well i know what it was i
don't need to ask
yeah yeah yeah that makes sense i don't
need to know all this but i'm gonna
connect
i'm gonna connect this to uh the wire
the where that makes sense to me
when you said jimmy came up with an idea
to do something nice for you
is that connected to what you said about
the coil of wire
ah come on it's good the why uh whatever
okay um
then it's definitely gotta be the bloody
the blood stained cloth when you said
jimmy came up with an idea to do
something nice for you
does that have something to do with the
blood-stained cloth if
that's not blood stained clothing it's
this
god damn it that's definitely
bloodstained cloth though
you said amy dying was why rose got in
touch with you
does that have something to do with the
blood-stained cloth
oh come on well that's so clearly
related
fine then found something nice to do for
you
huh something nice chef hat he wanted to
cook you a nice
meal jimmy came up with an idea to do
something nice for you
is that connected to what you said about
the chef's hat
[Music]
yes
i knew it i'm a genius god damn it my
brain is so huge
my brain is huge god my
throbbing noggin cool my nog
so throb my throb knog
i have to tell the world about my throb
nog
oh my god go go go please go i'm going
down the stairs
oh shortcut shortcut [ __ ] try to follow
me now [ __ ]
try me dickweed
choke on my
my throb nog
hello hi anybody here
oh good stuff hey you here
[Music]
huh okay well something's out oh
no this is a great idea jimmy
i reckon you'll make a great cook one
day oh why don't you bring it up to me
when you're done
i'll wait for you okay
okay all right yay cool man all right
hey that's awesome dude hey all right is
it dr boze
bose bo's my boy
oh spirit's too distant okay gotta move
closer apparently for some reason
here is this is blaze hello is it doctor
both
[Music]
i'm dr booze i'm sure you're outside the
kitchen talking to jimmy
yeah what were you doing what were you
doing
at first you say did he
put diazepam in your
was wrong does that have something to do
with what you said about the diazepam
oh don't make me use my
brain about this don't make me use my
brain when you said you didn't suspect
anything was wrong
does that have something to do with the
blood-stained cloth
it was my first encounter with jimmy's
sense of humor
i too have a what oh oh my god
oh my god
looks like i'm i'm going to three okay
so i'm guessing he put broken glass in
your sandwich and you
chomp that down like a big dummy fi if i
ever meet a jimmy
in my life which who knows maybe i have
i'm i'm
gonna never take sandwiches from them
also something tells me that jimmy might
should have been uh uh you know
looked into a bit deeper if all these
people just start dying around
them kind of curious that this hotel
still has plenty of patrons at this
establishment
hello
hi hello
okay slightly to this way you say
hello god i don't like these brisk
movement oh
so i'm over there or is that jimmy over
there hello
hello oh
well that's not good someone there
someone there very loud
[Music]
so i am nearby laid it up i'm telling
you to be lying about everything
probably lying about the other stuff as
well
ridiculous it wouldn't lie about
something like that you're sure about
that
he lies about everything open your
bloody eyes rose
oh that's right walk off i'm not
listening harley you've just got it in
for him
it's the truth you know maybe he's got a
point about something
maybe there's a little bit of a point
about that maybe maybe got a point you
know
maybe a bit of a point okay so what did
i find in here is the question
that's the question there's a big
kitchen right there i got a big question
about that what did i find
oh dear mom i'm sorry for everything
goodbye
was that from jimmy uh
all right then well
time to talk to a ghost there's someone
there someone there
oh hey what's up what's your name how
you doing
i saw a man saying jimmy had lied about
the assault
who was he it was me jimmy had made
accusations about the doctor
rose believed him i had heard that story
somewhere before
bloodstained cloth actually i should
talk about uh
him and uh i saw amy lying at the bottom
of the stairs she should ask him about
these what happened to her
she fell from the top floor down the
stairs
we had a display of medieval weapons
jimmy stole it
of course he did hey your proprietor you
would know about these suitcases right
who did they belong to who rose
but she never used them
interesting interesting interesting chef
chef the chef's gone
that's why jimmy wanted to be the chef
there was no chef chef
you'd heard the story somewhere before
is that connected to what you said about
the chef's hat
chef
i thought that maybe this chef would
have been fired or something because of
accusations made by jimmy or something
like that
but apparently i'm just dumb the ring
screw you said you'd heard the story
somewhere before is that connected to
the wedding room
oh well you know god damn
buh
okay it says i have paired these so
there's got to be something here
that i have not paired i saw the little
girl
amy holding a toy on fire what happened
she was burned pretty badly
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna say
goodbye for a second and i'm gonna go
into the scrying glass because
[Music]
why why are you being all wibbly wobbly
well give me the scribe give me the
scrye scribe me scry guy
subscribe me scribe me [ __ ]
one did i do it what one
one i don't know that i did so did i do
it don't eat me i didn't know if i did
two two two okay
wait but those are different things one
is on one one is on two two two
okay you know what i'm out of here i'm
gone [ __ ]
i'm leaving okay let's go two-two-two
first
i'm guessing that must be just like
items that i've not have and
need to get a hold of to get a better
understanding of everything that's going
on
because i'm guessing that i wouldn't
have nearly as many items in my
discoveries if i
was that way if i uh hadn't gone through
the whole hotel first so i wouldn't have
as many things to trial and error
what's down here what's what do we got
what do we got what do we got
two two one okay we're close to perfect
try hello so what's in here
well that's handy that's awfully handy
but only margin
that's what i need to ask a dude about
okay so i got a scrapbook
but it also the scrymer said i need to
go down to one so i'm gonna go ahead and
go down to one
okay which one
pardon no
god what not that the thing obviously
the thing obviously the thing
hello someone taking a wicked piss oh
oh oh god i thought you were taking a
[ __ ]
[Music]
fun oh oh god save oh god okay
dr bozey is it doctor bose
dr bose yes
hi dr bose hey saw you spitting out
blood
[Music]
urgently oh god wait
is he like standing right there
oh my god i'm gonna ignore you
you don't exist it's fine hey how you
doing man you said you needed to step up
jimmy's treatment
second something to do with the blood
stain one second jimmy
should be standing there with his bat
waiting all right you know what good hey
i'm going to turn this up
come on
in and here and here here we go
106 is perfect i have that key i'm never
going to get it in time
oh my god oh god not
not near 106. haha [ __ ]
you laugh of a storm [ __ ]
oh there he is try it try it [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] i win
[Music]
what are you even saying i don't even
understand what you're talking about
shut up
you fool
[Laughter]
i'm leaving now going leaving now
leaving promptly promptly now leaving
going away now
should look in the sky because i don't
know where i'm going
number three
[Music]
okay i might need to go back to uh scry
guy but no that's
it looks like it's pointing right at the
levator
let's go to ground jimmy's being a real
prick he's getting worse gonna have to
teach him a lesson eventually and by
that lesson i mean i'm going to
teach him about the sheer blunt force
trauma that my
fists can inflict on his face
that was a really nerdy way of
threatening somebody but i did it and
i'm proud of it
is it pointing here no it's not pointing
there i just wanted to get here so i
could scry
what am i looking at oh what am i
looking at oh it's it's the diazepam
one okay one one we got one i can do one
come on let's get out of the sky come on
we gotta go we gotta go
[Music]
oh that's the article that i just got
guess i did need to go to three but i'm
gonna go to one first
i'm guessing that's just saying that
both of those characters are on
different places so i'm gonna go to one
first because why not and then i'll go
to
three later
okay hello hi oh was i supposed to still
talk to bish mr bozo
was i still supposed to talk to mr bozo
ah is someone there i wasn't done
right i know i'm bozo boze bose hey we
got interrupted
i didn't even realize that it wasn't
done right it wouldn't be about the
scrapbook
i saw a scrapbook with newspapers
although that is curious
who made it jimmy made it
it was a warning i wish you should have
seen it coming
saying what calming okay you needed to
step up jimmy's treatment urgently
does that have something to do with what
you said about the diazepam
it wasn't the ideal medication but it
was
jimmy needed treating immediately he was
dangerous he sure was he
sure was buddy boo he sure is
he sure is now currently ah
two i see i'm sure this treatment went
over swimmingly for old gymster here
and i'm sure the jimbo really took a no
no no no
i'm sure timbo took a real real uh
kindness to what you were showing him
all right let's go to two
i knew it i knew he would be there
waiting for me
oh i knew it all right which way am i
going i gotta go quick
he's gonna come over here
okay it's over here where is it
oh okay not helpful okay it must be in
one of these
[Music]
spirit too distant oh okay this way in
this room
let's give it a look where'd all my
friends go by the way there's a whole
problem with all my friends being
kidnapped and in the various
rooms in this hotel that's still a thing
happening or do i not need to worry
about that anymore thank you deadlock
good luck cool doctor bows
boaster boze man
i saw you with a needle talking to jimmy
what were you doing
jimmy defuse let me administer the truck
i had to chase him around the hotel
then he told rose i tried to force him
to take it
that i'd used violence it was ridiculous
hmm was it so ridiculous
was it so ridiculous was it
when you said jimmy refused to let you
administer his medicine
does that have something to do with what
you said about the scrapbook
oh come on it's so clear it's so clear
what about the assault who was he
[Music]
i'm gonna go right to the sky i'm going
right to the sky
100 scry
haddle
[Music]
paddle huddle
i get it
[Music]
when you said jimmy refused to let you
administer his medicine
is that connected to what you said about
the wooden paddle jimmy said i used the
paddle
[Music]
yeah rose sounds like she would have
done that
oh come on just
a little weapon all right so that's that
time to go to the third floor
i don't remember it being as windy oh hi
mannequins
how you doing i don't remember this
hallway here
that's very concerning are you pointed
behind me i don't know where that
compass is pointing it's it's just
drifting aimlessly so i'm guessing that
means there's just nothing here
uh yeah let me go that way
[Music]
oh my god i saw that
demonic
oh my god
be still my heart i'm probably fine
probably fine fine let's go
let's go for it
no way he heard that
what was he doing in that little corner
you saw him guys didn't you
i hated that i hated that i hated it so
much
all right where are we gonna go now
all right comfy don't leave me astray
well that doesn't help me much at all
all right let's just go probably gotta
wrap around all the way around
no no no not this way i think this door
here yeah
what was this one okay
oh my god hello
yeah i know you can okay so i remember
you saying something about jimmy lied
uh is it harvey
okay good jimmy lied scrapbook
with newspaper articles in it who made
it
jimmy he used to keep cut out some news
stories about
[Music]
does that have something to do with what
you said about the scrapbook
it came straight out of it
[Music]
interesting
well all right then i guess we're good
here
take a look before i go out but it said
something about three again so there's
something else on this floor
that i need to see i just gotta find it
which way you pointing which way oh god
oh my god
oh who's running oh god no
what have i done here here
oh [ __ ] oh god damn
oh who's there no
oh god no
i'm just gonna do a quick scry
just get my head on straight and then
i'll know exactly what i need to do
but you said three
oh for the the doctor three g
for this guy three somewhere up here
there's another story to be heard
oh oh interesting oh
so i gotta look through a looking glass
lookie-loo
of some room specifically uh so i gotta
find that room
i gotta find that room all right i don't
know why jimmy is scampering
i don't like a scamper i don't like
scampering
it really seems like it might be this
room but it's not i mean i can't go in
there anyway do i have the
key to that 305 i don't think i have any
three keys
why are you scampering why stop it
[Music]
you don't know that here this one
oh it's dark goddammit dork
okay it's not that one oh oh my god in
the bathroom oh my god
oh boy there's no way he don't know
there's no way he don't know there's no
way he
don't know
[Music]
well at least he doesn't just straight
up murder me that's so nice of him
that's awfully kind of him good sir
who made who do what thing who made who
do what who did what now
where am i oh another dark room that's
yes
that's great that's that's good okay i'm
gonna leave that there for now i need to
go find my ghosty goo
but i'm 37 of the story complete which
is great
good stuff good stuff so thank you
everybody so much for watching
i am thoroughly enjoying this and we
will continue this
in another episode thank you let me know
what you thought down in the comments
below
if you know all of jimmy's crimes keep
them to yourself
and don't tell me or anyone else because
i want to find out for myself
thank you and as always i will see you
in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye